at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking organism living facility this
episode is brought to you by athletic
greens I get asked all the time if you
could only use one supplement what would
it be and my answer is inevitably
athletic greens it is your all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
in the 4-hour body did not get paid for
that and I travel with it to avoid
getting sick I take it in the mornings
to ensure optimal performance it just
covers all my bases if I can't get what
I need through whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day and you
can get 50 oh my god 50% off yes 50% off
if you go to athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim that's athletic greens
calm forward-slash Tim check it out it's
tasty but more important it will help
you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind
puts a lot in my body and check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I have
used 99designs for everything from
banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock-ups that led to the
4-hour body which later became number
one New York Times number-one Wall
Street Journal and the brainstorming a
lot of it took place with designers from
around the world and here's how it works
whether you need a t-shirt a business
card a website and app thumbnail
whatever it might be you submit that
project and designers from around the
world will send you sketches and
mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs
come forward / Tim that's 99designs
dot-com forward / Tim hello ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and I'd like
to ask you why are so serious
we're gonna get back to that but this is
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where my job is to try to deconstruct
world-class performers to try to
identify the things that make them as
good as they are at what they do that is
a mouthful of a sentence whether that is
their morning routines their favorite
books etc etc and this episode is a fun
one because we're going to focus on how
to use games to get more done with less
stress among many other things and my
guest is none other than Jane McGonigal
PhD one of my favorite peeps Jane is a
senior researcher at the Institute for
the future and the author of the New
York Times bestseller reality is broken
subtitle why games make us better and
how they can change the world her work
has been featured in The Economist Wired
The New York Times on and on she has
been called one of the top 10 innovators
to watch my Businessweek and one of the
100 most creative people in business by
Fast Company her TED talks on games had
been viewed more than 10 million times
she knows of what she speaks and in this
conversation we dig into everything from
recovering from head trauma to how you
can use candy crush saga to lose weight
and if that's not enough we talk about
how to use Tetris to prevent PTSD or
perhaps call of duty to increase empathy
and there are many other options it's a
very very cool discussion with a lot of
science underlying all of it her latest
book is super better and I would like to
ask you guys a favor I got an advance
copy I've really been enjoying it and
testing it and I want to ask you to go
buy a copy of this book so super better
it's on Amazon check it out but what is
the premise SuperBetter offers a
revolutionary and science-based approach
for getting stronger happier and more
resilient like I said I've been testing
it myself and it works not only am I
feeling better and that's typically a
sort of a morning issue or a late at
night issue but I'm having more fun in
the process
and as adults I think we often
tract of play my hope is that this
episode will help you to reclaim it it's
not frivolous it can help you get a lot
more done with less stress so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with Jane McGonigal Jane welcome to the
show thank you Tim I am so excited to
finally reconnect it has been many years
and I have enthusiastically watched you
are sort of your your growth and
propagation of all these ideas that I
hope will have a chance to explore in
this conversation but I missed quite a
lot and what we'll get to for instance
just the the the head trauma I didn't
know anything about but before we get to
the serious stuff tell me about your
dogs and the names of your dogs well I
have two Shetland Sheepdogs
and their names actually reflect a
pretty good evolution of my sort of work
and interest in game design so my oldest
dog Mitch a a girl is named after my
favorite video game character from grim
fandago and my new puppy Stanga who's
only two is named after my favorite
tennis player and I I think I people
asking about games I'm playing and I'm
actually playing more tennis than video
games these days so when somebody asks
you for those people listening or not
familiar with your work what do you do
how do you answer that I usually lie
actually because like George Costanza
style oh yeah I mean I've told I've been
in like on an airplane someone asked me
what I do and I tell them I'm a cab
driver and they're like why are you
flying to China and I'll say oh I'm
getting an award for being a really
innovative cab driver I mean I yeah it's
hard to get because it's hard to explain
to people well I research games and I
design games and I try to design games
to help people be happier and healthier
and saves the world and then then you
spend the whole eight-hour flight you
know answering questions about it so and
well instead of an eight-hour flight
we're gonna have a long podcast about
all
I'm afraid you can't dodge me with the
taxi driver again that this time around
but is it am I correct in saying that
you're the the you were the first person
to earn a PhD studying the psychological
strengths of gamers and how they and how
they can apply them to real life so I
would I was the first person to really
take seriously the idea that people who
you know spend an hour a day or more
playing particularly video games might
have some unique strengths cognitive
strengths social strengths imaginative
strengths that could be applied to
real-world problems and what what would
some of those problems be and of course
I have some familiar familiar with this
because I've I'm a fan of your writing
and I was also a an early reader of your
first book but could you give some
examples of what types of real-world
problems can be either dressed partly
partially or solved potentially by by
gamers sure well you know I've been
working with the Institute for the
future in Palo Alto for oh gosh eight
eight nine years now and one of my
favorite kinds of games to create is
future of forecasting games so to invite
ordinary people to try to predict their
own futures and then when you get enough
people predicting their own futures you
can learn some really interesting trends
it's sort of it's sort of like a
collective intelligence project where
you might not be able to predict what
will happen in the rest of the world but
if I tell you a short scenario you know
peak oil scenario you can very
accurately predict what you would do how
you would get to work how you get your
kids to school what what you would cook
and we take all that information and
aggregate it to understand how the world
might react to different future
scenarios that's my kind of game so no
this is this is very interesting I mean
I know that for instance and you could
probably elaborate on this but whether
you're looking at say protein folding
right you could use excess processing
power from
gaming units to sort of collectively
handle a lot of very gnarly computation
right but in this particular case are
you getting pinged by hedge fund
managers and people like that who want
to try to develop investment theses
around those types of scenarios oh sure
yeah you know I was the first game
designer to be invited to give a keynote
at Davos right so there there are
definitely powerful people interested in
these although I'm I'm happy to say that
you know my work at the Institute for
the future it's a nonprofit organization
and we're mostly trying to help the
world you know survive environmental
catastrophe and pandemics and things
like that so I've been used more for
more for global good than individual
profit so far
well I and I suppose though there there
could be an interesting conversation
about how you can utilize both right or
make them in some in some in some
respect a virtuous cycle so if you have
people who are incentivized right to
help develop games that drive their
perhaps their own benefit but at the
same time they're facilitating the
development of toolkits or architectures
or whatever that address these larger
scale problems facing humanity I don't
know it's it's it is a it is a very
interesting conversation but I don't
want to take us too far off topic
immediately could you please describe to
folks and this is much for my at to
satisfy my curiosity is anything else
but the concussion so I I'm ashamed to
say I knew nothing about this but could
you describe for people what happened
and sort of what what happened after
that incident sure well you know while
it was happening not a lot of people
knew I actually tried to hide it for a
long time because I was so impacted by
the concussion that I was afraid I would
never be able to work again you know I
was afraid I'd never built this feat
publicly because I couldn't remember
things long enough to to put together a
talk I was in the middle of writing my
first book and I thought oh my god I'm
never gonna finish my book my publishers
know I mean I was you know I was not
screaming from the rooftops that I was
having so many problems but it was
sequence the summer of 2009 and I was
just an ordinary day rushing around my
apartment and wound up hitting my head
on an open cabinet door did you like
step up did you stand up quickly like he
need a hip and whack your head or how
did you go it can I do here head I did I
sometimes people ask me if it was a
sports injury and I say yes kind of
because I am a runner like a marathon
runner and so I very strong quads and I
just I was in such a hurry I just used
like the full force of my clouds how hot
and it was it was crazy I mean literally
it was out of out of a movie my husband
was like joking around oh you know who's
the president and the only thing I could
remember was that it wasn't George Bush
I'm like I know it's not George Bush but
I couldn't I couldn't even remember who
the president was a boy that's when I
knew okay this is uh this is bad and it
was really bad so a lot of concussions
heal within a week but after the first
month I was still completely concussed I
mean all day every day nauseous vertigo
couldn't remember people's names lost
everything I would put something down
never find it again and I I couldn't
even really get out of bed I couldn't
talk to people it was it was a disaster
and my my current work my new book my my
new game the clinical trial I'm running
all of that comes out of my attempt to
use game design to fix my brain and the
this is you did a great job of hiding it
for those people who were not
interacting with you on a daily basis
because we had we had quite a bit of
interaction for reality's broken and
while you were finishing that so this
was happening at the same time that we
were interacting so all right that would
be fun to take up the emails and see see
if they read like haikus
Wow you know I had a very similar
experience last year with Lyme disease I
try to keep it under wraps but with with
respect to the concussion can you
describe then what followed I mean
because you you had some very dark
periods and I just loved to hear how
this work that you're doing now at least
some of it evolved out of that
concussion and by the way I'm like the
world's expert on concussions now
because I've learned every bit of
research that has ever been done so one
of the things I learned is that there is
a 30-day window for recovering from
concussion most people recover within 30
days and if you miss that window then
they tell you that the next window is
three months and and then if you miss
that window if you're still having all
these symptoms then it's likely to be a
year and if you are still totally
symptomatic in a year then you may have
the symptoms forever now that was
something I learned on day 34 of my
concussion when my doctor told me oh you
know you've sort of missed the first
window of recovery of 30 days so this
could drag out for for three months and
and at that point you know you have to
imagine I couldn't do anything I I mean
you're basically on bed rest but you
can't I couldn't watch you know TV
unless with episodes I'd seen before
because I'll get really confused by the
plot like I remember watching an episode
of TV and just like who are these
characters I can't keep it straight so
you can't do anything you can't go
running you're not.you can't drink
coffee because it a great symptoms so I
was more depressed and then ever been in
my life I was super anxious that I would
never work again and you know my husband
had just been laid off from his job so
the only upside of that was that he was
able to stay at home and care for me but
the downside being either one of us was
working and so I was just I mean as a
total mess and sometime in that first
you know 30 days I also to make things
even more dramatic and awful started to
have suicidal ideation which you know
just meant that I was sort of hearing
new voices
in my head you want to you should kill
yourself you're never gonna get better
you're gonna be a burden to your family
this you know every day is going to be
this awful for the rest of your life
just get out now
and I did not know at the time how they
found out later that this is actually
really common with traumatic brain
injuries that it happens to one in three
people who even just from a mild
concussion one in three people will have
suicidal thoughts which first of all we
should tell everybody because when it
starts to happen to you it's it's such a
relief to know that it's not your brain
actually wanting to die right that it's
just it's just the neuro chemistry of
the brain your joke Amin levels are I
mean zero out you literally your brain
cannot imagine any positive outcomes in
the future you have no access to
dopamine and so literally it is
impossible to imagine anything good ever
happening again while the brain is
trying to heal so if this is like this
is where I went and I was I was
basically you know worried that I was
gonna kill myself and and and and then
my doctor was like oh yeah and you've
missed the window of recovery here so
you know good luck for another three
months and if you know maybe you'll be
like this forever
so that that was that was where things
went that was that was rock bottom and
how did you dig yourself out of that I
mean what were the conversations or
interactions that allowed you to get out
of that hole because there are people
who don't get out of it right and like
you said it's important to have these
conversations so that people can view it
as a collective symptom and not a
personal singular individualized flaw
but how did you how did you start
turning the corner what was it well
there were two key things going on that
summer that really helped me so the
first was I had been writing my book the
first book reality's broken which is all
about how games make us happy and
there's happiness engines and I thought
well [ __ ] this is this I should really
really really tough these theories out
you know take this really seriously
because if anything could jumpstart my
brain into being happy
even though dopamine was zeroed out and
in my brain was telling me I wanted to
die well games should be able to do it
the other thing that was going on that
summer was I was watching re watching
the entire Buffy the Vampire Slayer you
just earned so much dork cred because
because I knew all the episodes so well
so it wasn't taxing to my brain so so I
was watching Buffy and I just decided
you know I'm gonna try to turn this
recovery process into more of a game
because I know games make us more
optimistic and motivated and and it's
you know it's easier to ask people for
help when we're playing a game and it so
I decided to just invent this game
called gene the concussion Slayer and I
was gonna be like Buffy the Vampire
Slayer who did not choose to be this
layer right fate just thrusted upon her
and she had to just step up to the
heroic occasion and and I was going to
step up to my own heroic occasion and
and treat all these symptoms like demons
and vampires and and just be a badass
that that was that and that was the
start of a game that I played for the
rest of the year and that now half a
million people have played and that we
just around a big clinical trial on so
it's been and that was it's been but
almost six years that that kind of crazy
idea has been developing into something
you know much but much much bigger now
and I feel like Rip Van Winkle I'm so
embarrassed that we haven't talked about
this before I got an early copy of the
new book which by the way I should just
say it's super better that I get sent a
lot of books and my assistant sees all
of these books and this is the first
time that she said to me when you're
finished with that book I'd like you to
give it to me
very very very fascinating and I'm
already into the book which is saying a
lot because it's it's one you know I get
20 30 bucks a week and this is the one
that I'm focusing on right now and it's
partially because I want to fix my own
problems right and and in reading the
introduction you talk about
being gameful and I'd love for you to
talk about that and then also just talk
about the first incarnation of the game
as you played it for yourself sure well
I am excited you want to talk about what
it needs to be gainful because I feel
like this is a really good opportunity
to kind of set the record straight about
something that makes me crazy which is
the topic of gamification yes you know
the idea that you can just give people
points for doing stuff and that's going
to motivate them and give them
achievement badges and that's going to
make them feel proud and it's like a
very simplistic notion of motivation and
reward and I don't do it even though
like if you look up gamification on
Wikipedia it's like Jean McGonagall did
you see that word in my book no I don't
do it I like to think that I think when
I get motivational speaker and I'm like
oh my god I've got to live with that one
forever so so this book is really about
something totally different which is the
game full mindset which is a way of
approaching obstacles and stress that
most of us naturally adopt when we play
games when we play sports or we're doing
puzzles or for games card games video
games almost every single person on this
planet and throughout history has been
able to adopt a very powerful mindset
that makes us better able to learn from
our mistakes more determined in the face
of obstacles better able to amass
resources from other people build allies
and all these really wonderful things
that help us solve problems but few of
us use that same mindset in everyday
life like we only use it in games and so
that's what I've been researching since
my brain healed you know took about a
year that's been the new research topic
that I've been obsessed with which is
how do we help people take all the
benefits of a gameful mindset which mean
you're more creative you're less likely
to give up you've got better social
support you know more curiosity
our optimism all these wonderful things
how do we bring that into the real world
and it doesn't necessarily mean
gamifying anything if it turns out it's
the most important thing you can do to
really access your gameful mindset is to
play games any games that you like and
then remember to call on those same
strengths in real life so how did you do
that then initially when digging
yourself out of this hole and I think
it's it's it's also important I think a
lot of people listening or like wow like
they're imagining sitting in front of a
screen playing Zelda or a first-person
shooter game or something like that but
what did what did you do concretely for
yourself and in the beginning and then
how is that evolved right I mean it
really wasn't even a game so much as it
was a process for being gainful in
everyday life so you know the first
thing I did was adopt this secret
identity retain the concussion Slayer
and the idea behind that is it was just
like an avatar for real life you know
when we have avatars and video games
we're really focused on you know what
are they good at what are their
strengths how can i level up those
strengths what are their special secret
weapons how do they use them we're very
focused on strengths and the the skill
sets and so I wanted to start focusing
on you know what are my strengths and
skill sets even though I feel completely
hopeless and helpless and like I can't
do a single thing right to adopt that
that kind of avatar for everyday life
and it was not a digital avatar on a
screen it was literally me just telling
people I'm Jane the concussion and
Slayer and as it turns out now that I've
done all this research literally just
talking about yourself in the third
person with a focus on your strengths
it's this incredible kind of brain hack
that I mean it changes so much in terms
of anxiety and depression I said that
was the first thing that I did so this
one I'm an avatar so when you would go
like get a cup of tea at Starbucks and
they're like what's your name miss
you know but but but is this something
that who would you use that name with
you know I first started just with my
closest inner-circle you know I called
my sister my twin sister Kelly who is a
psychology professor at Stanford
University by the way so I got a lot of
good tips from her and you know I'm like
oh I'm playing this game to heal my
brain I want you to play it with me I'm
gonna be Jane the concussion Slayer and
I want you to be my watcher so I
actually adopted the mythology from the
Buffy series to give everybody of my
life like a particular ally role to play
so you know if you remember Buffy her
watcher Giles he would oversee her
training so my sister's job was to give
me one thing to do every day like a
little quests or mission and then she
would call me the next day to see how I
did and that was actually amazing
because I had not really done anything
successfully until she started giving me
missions and did stupid things like okay
can you see out the window from the bed
that you're not able to get out of yes
okay I want you to look out the window
and find one interesting thing like try
to see one interesting thing and tell me
about it tomorrow you know when we talk
like spots something kind of crazy
outside your window and then then I was
able have a sense of purpose for the day
like I'm lying in bed with nothing to do
but I have a have a goal now I have a
mission and it turns out I learned from
all my research later that having a
clear goal and being able to anticipate
succeeding in that goal that's one of
the fastest ways to get the dopamine
back cycling through your brain which is
which is key to reversing depression so
so you can just being given a little
tiny quest it's like you know a good
good role playing game like World of
Warcraft here's here's somebody who
comes up to you and says I have a quest
for you do you accept it and you and you
agree to do it that's like that's also
like a brain hack where you're just
spiking those dopamine levels and
learning to anticipate success again
well that's a you know I've I've been
thinking a lot about resource allocation
that's the most boring way I could
possibly put it but I've been thinking
about how people allocate different
currencies right time
income and so on and looking at the
difference for instance between buying
possessions or experiences and the the
data very strongly support the
psychological superiority of buying
experiences generally speaking because
the value of a purchase
decreases very quickly I mean it's it's
like driving a new car off the lot and
suddenly it's depreciated 30% but when
you plan and I experienced this last
year for myself when you plan and let's
say a trip six months from now you have
those six months of anticipation and I
recently took I took my family on our
first real family outing and many many
many years and we went to Iceland but it
was something that we planned for
Christmas and New Year's and we had a
good five or six months to look forward
to it and it just made all of the bumps
along the way C minor and and very
easily overcome so putting that and it
just gave us some some North Star to
look towards when the going got rough
right so what other what other aspects
or what other features did you did you
build into your life so you had your
sister secret identity you have allies
that you recruit and then you have these
quests that your allies give you we also
collected an activated powerup so in
this in the system power-ups or anything
that give you a quick burst of a
positive emotion any any feeling at all
it could be pleasure it could be you
know laughter it could be delight
whatever and so I started collecting you
know like cuddling with my dog for ten
minutes would be a powerup or listening
to a powerful song that made me feel
powerful or eating walnuts because that
was supposed to be good for brain
healing and so just trying to identify
things you could do and just them like a
minute or two to create a positive
experience which you know having a
traumatic brain injury is kind of
extreme example of needing power-ups
because you otherwise literally you just
lie there in a state of you know abject
you know just boredom or frustration but
making sure that you have these tiny
moments of positive emotions because as
I've learned now in all my research
happiness and success and a good health
can coexist with all kinds of negative
emotions and you don't actually have to
get rid of your negative emotions to be
really successful in thriving you just
have to balance them out with positive
emotions so the most look happy and
successful people actually have more
negative emotions than people who are
depressed or anxious or struggling they
just manage to balance them out with
even more positive emotions so these
power-ups are just a way to kind of game
the math every time you feel something
really bad you try to do a couple quick
things that will make you feel happy
right to offset it to tilt the balance
in your favor yes and and and how is
that what is the current game look like
when you have people for instance seeing
measurable improvements within two weeks
and even bigger improvements between
four to six weeks and you have hundreds
of thousands of people who have played
what is the the current state of that
game or the the format so there's a
website and there is an app and it's
again it's not a video game it's it's
like a life management tool where we
walk you through the process of hey do
you think you might have a secret
identity here are some ways that you can
investigate it you know we have you
think about who your heroes are your
favorite fictional characters are what
your strengths are until you are able to
craft one we ask you to collect
power-ups we we find out more about you
and we say oh you're trying to lose
weight okay here are 10 power-ups that
we validate it to be really helpful for
other players or here are 10 bad guys
that we know that people who are
struggling with anxiety they also
struggle with and strategies for for
wrestling with them so we bad guys also
and so we just kind of walk you through
the process of looking at your life as
if
were a game so it's almost like you're
the game designer you craft your secret
identity you pick your power-ups and
define your bad guys and and you
eventually create your own quests and
get the help of your own allies who you
invite and we just sort of teach you the
process of thinking and living like a
game designer by offering you here's
some here's some sample power-ups and
bad guys in class to get started let's
let's let's talk about I mean I'm gonna
come back to the power-ups because I
think for those people who haven't
played games it might be easy to dismiss
these things as childish but I have did
some personal experimentation today
which is which was pretty fun with some
of your exercises haha but let's talk
about some games that people might be
familiar with for instance candy crush
saga yes
and so I've I've read you all right I've
noticed that candy crush saga has been
talked about is being used to lose
weight in some cases and I wanted to
just hear you elaborate on that so this
is amazing there are so many games now
that people are playing every day and
have no idea that they're powerful
life-changing tools so candy crush saga
has only half a billion people have
played this game and it's like 0.000001
percent of them know that there have
been these clinical studies showing that
a game like candy crush saga can reduce
cravings for things like food or
cigarettes by 25% which sounds like not
a lot but it's actually been shown to be
enough of a reduction of the craving
that you can make a better choice so
sort of gives your willpower a fighting
chance and the way it works is the game
is so visually intensive right so a game
like candy crush saga or bejeweled or
Tetris the kind of games where when you
walk away you see these sort of visual
flashbacks you see the blocks falling or
you see that the pieces swapping they
occupy the visual processing center of
your brain so that you cannot imagine
the thing that you're craving and it
turns out that cravings are very visual
you've anyone who's ever out of craving
knows you a mad
what you want and the more that you see
it in your mind's eye the more
irresistible the craving is so it turns
out that you can just get your brain to
stop picturing it and obsess it with
some other visual process you can block
cravings not just while you're playing
but afterwards because these games have
been shown to create this kind of visual
flashbacks your brain thinks it still
needs to keep working on this problem
because you were so focused on it so
your brain is going to keep working on
this visual process and even hours after
you've walked away from the game that
can last you know 3-4 hours
you've played just for 10 minutes but
your brain is no longer obsessing over
the thing that you were craving it's
it's like that's fascinating there are
like so many studies like this that this
is one of the reasons why I wanted to
write the book and you Tim you actually
inspired me because when you know when I
read the 4-hour body and you're like
people there's all this amazing science
and you should be experimenting with it
in your own life and you know that's
that's kind of where game research is
now - it's you know you know people
still have a little bit of skepticism
and and rightly so because you know we
haven't tested the candy crush saga diet
over 10 years with you know 10,000
people but it's so easy to test in your
own life and with no downside most of
these games are completely free to play
and so I'm just like wow people should
be experimenting with this in their own
lives because studies there are you know
I think this book cites a thousand
peer-reviewed scientific studies so
there is a lot of research we just need
to help people get their hands on it so
well thank you for the for kind words I
appreciate that I mean the eye eye eye
sometimes push it so far that you know I
hope it serves as a cautionary tale to
others but you know I'm like it let me
be the guy's sort of getting himself
perfused in in any number of ways so
that you don't have to be that person
but the the candy crush saga diet let's
talk about that or let's just let's say
you know you smoke when you go out and
drink and if the effects last like three
to four
does that mean that a potential
prescription would be to play candy
crush saga for say 15 minutes before you
head out for Friday night I mean is that
that the way that it might be used as an
intervention yeah absolutely
and that's that is a recurring finding
in a lot of these studies is that a very
short dose of play can provide this kind
of these preventive benefits for hours
or even one of the studies all read
about in the book two hours of gameplay
change the players behavior for three
months afterwards yes I don't know if
you've gotten to the chapter yet about
the cancer patients who were were better
able to take all their chemotherapy
medicine because they played a video
game have you I have not gotten up which
video game is this the game is called
remission is cancer related yeah and
there's actually a sequel that's out now
- which is awesome and they're they're
all free-to-play the remission games so
if you know anybody anyone who's
listening who has a friend or family
member or it's battling cancer this game
has been shown at clinical trials to
improve the patient's first of all
optimism and self efficacy they don't
feel so powerless in the face of cancer
but also to increase the doses of
chemotherapy that they're able to take
when you're if certain kinds of cancers
like leukemia you have to take these
pills for two years three years at home
ongoing basis with all these kinds of
side effects and almost more than a
third of patients miss a significant
number of doses because of the side
effects or because it's really hard to
never miss a pill on schedule over two
to three years but they know that more
than 80% of cases where the cancer comes
back is related to miss doses so if you
can get people to not miss any doses you
have dramatically improved their
recovery outcomes and then so this group
called hope lab in Palo Alto created a
game designed to basically they didn't
know what they were doing but they
basically hacked these patients brains
to chain
change how they viewed themselves and
how they viewed chemotherapy so that
they started to view it as empowering
rather than something that made them
sick or that they hated and it it was
able to hack into their hippocampus and
the caudate and thalamus which we know
are related to motivation and not giving
up and they know this because they did
brain scans of the players and had them
in fMRI machines and looking at the
brains while they played the game so
they could see what was actually going
on to change their behavior over a
three-month period but the upshot is
that you know when they measured their
blood three months later the cancer
patients who had played remission for as
little as two hours had 41% more
chemotherapy medicine in their
bloodstream and they had missed 18 or 19
percent fewer doses of antibiotics as
well which they use electronic fill cat
monitors to measure and and and and that
was over three-month period two hours of
playing the video game this is a big
clinical trial they ran with dozens of
hospitals around the United States so
it's amazing that these games exist and
that I think I think something like a
quarter of a million cancer patients
have have been given access to these
games now but if you kind of want every
cancer patient to get access to them
yeah what's the downside right exactly
that's the thing about games as
treatment there is extremely little risk
of negative side effects or kind of
opportunity costs because you can do a
game alongside traditional therapy for
depression or if you know you feel like
you want to you have some kind of
pharmaceutical solution that you're
pursuing games really add no downside
and all upside so let's talk about just
a couple of other games Tetris and Call
of Duty mm-hmm
can this be used in any particular way
yeah Tetris oh by way is so exciting
because literally yesterday a new study
came out about Tetris that validates the
studies that I write about in the book
and I was so excited because people have
actually been a little bit skeptical
about when I encourage people to play
Tetris
to help prevent post-traumatic stress
disorder I wish I will now explain how
that works people are like oh that could
be really dangerous to tell people to do
that because what if they never see a
therapist because they think they've
cured themselves with Tetris right so
because you always have to preface this
by saying if you're having problems you
know you should see a doctor or
therapist but it turns out that if you
play Tetris within six hours of
witnessing a traumatic event they've
only tested it on witnessing trauma
rather than you know you yourself were
traumatized directly but if you if you
play Tetris for 10 minutes after
witnessing a trauma it prevents
flashbacks and lowers symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder
afterwards and it's really actually very
similar to how the candy crush saga diet
works in that overriding your visual
examination yeah exactly prevents your
brain from kind of obsessing over what
you saw and what's amazing is this new
study that would just came out this week
shows that if you miss that six-hour
window because one of the reasons why
people were skeptical was who's gonna
remember to play Tetris within six hours
of a trauma even though I've been doing
my best to kind of create public service
announcements so people know kind of
like stop drop and roll if you catch on
fire you remember that something roll
right so I'm trying I'm trying to like
drill into people's heads you know play
Tetris don't replay the trauma like play
don't replay if you were like nobody's
gonna remember after trauma to play so
now they have found out that you can
actually wait 24 hours and if you re
stimulate the memory you ask somebody to
visualize the trauma for just a minute
or two so it's kind of fresh in their
brain the brain is accessing those
memories and dealing with them directly
and then you go play Tetris for 10
minutes you can kind of you're not
erasing the memory you're like
overwriting it well it's it's as
interesting so they this is super
critical detail you can still recall the
experience if you're asked questions you
can remember details of the experience
so it's not like it's not like a Eternal
Sunshine of this
was mine you can see you can still
remember but your brain is not forcing
you to think about it when you don't
want to so it's voluntary recall only
and so this new study shows you can wait
24 hours prime yourself by thinking
about it and then play Tetris for 10
minutes right afterwards and then that
reduces the flashbacks and PTSD symptoms
as well and they think you know if it
can work after 24 hours that this might
be able to work with people who have
been suffering for months or years with
flashbacks now - which is which is
amazing because it is literally the
hardest to treat symptom a post
traumatic stress disorder and when
people get flashbacks under control
their quality of life improves
immeasurably know and call of duty call
of duty they're like a million things
that call of duty does really well
you've already covered some of that on a
previous podcast I know you're talking
about sort of cognitive enhancement
benefits so with Adam Ghazali yeah UCSF
Yahoo's amazing love I love his work
okay so we will talk about cognitive
enhancement but Call of Duty can well
the first thing you can do is it can
really improve relationships with people
if you play in the same room with them
so if you can actually be physically in
the same space with somebody playing
with them because it dramatically
increases mind-body synchronization so
what that means is if you're playing
called Judi with someone in the same
room you start to sync up with them at
every possible level your breathing
rates you'll start to breathe in and out
at the same pace your heart rates will
synchronize so your pulses are kind of
equalized
your facial expressions will start to
mirror each other your body language
will reach other and your brains will
actually that will start to show blood
flow in the same region and the same
tempo as each other that they call that
mirror neuron effect and it happens
actually happens in basically all video
games but the more intense sort of
high-speed fast action intense the game
is the more it happens because in order
to do well in a game whether you're
competing against someone or
collaborating with them on the same team
you have to be able to anticipate
what they're going to do next right so
that you can either cooperate and be
effective or so that you can outmaneuver
them and beat them and that that forces
your brain to try to mirror what their
brain is doing and as soon as your brain
starts familiar each other everything
else works for each other and it turns
out this is like the building block for
compassion and love so basically you
love people more when you play call duty
with them but only only if you're in the
same physical space yes so something I
wish it's not usually spend i mean most
gamers are you know playing with people
remotely in a distance but if you can
get in the same room that is really
magnificent benefit so i'm gonna i'm
gonna take a digression into what might
be an urban myth or it's not really an
urban myth old wives tale not also not
totally appropriate but you are you have
an identical twin
mm-hmm yes do you have you the two of
you experienced anything that's kind of
like spooky accent action at a distance
and you must be sick of this type of
question but i'm really curious
well you see now you're gonna like i
have to you know i'm really into science
so now i will say something that will
sound like oh you know mystical
spiritual can I add a caveat just to to
make it easier yeah I believe a bunch of
stuff that seems quacker than the quack
iya stuff I mean it but it's from a
empirical first-hand experience and just
because we can't explain it doesn't mean
we won't be able to explain it yeah no I
I think there's actually probably some
you know that in physics they talk about
these like you can have the twin effect
like protons will be separated but then
still be able to communicate at a
distance like you know a billion
light-years away from each other in the
galaxy so maybe the fact that we were
once the same egg we're identical twins
you know and we maybe maybe we have some
weird spooky twin effect so yeah I call
it twinfection because it only works
yeah if something really horrible is
happening to my sister so I will like I
will
I'm having a heart attack I'm gonna
throw up my like I can't breathe I feel
like I'm being attacked it just happened
a couple years ago during a really
emotionally traumatic time but this is
the most reason it doesn't happen all
the time it really only happens if
something truly horrible is going on and
I was like I was at it I was at a store
in Los Angeles I like fell to the floor
in the dressing room like what's going
on and then literally two minutes later
you know my sister called me sobbing
like the worst pain I'd ever hurt her
and it was she was dealing with the
death and the family and I was like okay
well that explains what just happened
because you know we were I was having a
twinfection
yeah Wow and yet you you have a pretty
twin rich life at the moment I have
little twin babies my own little twin
girls are they identical or fraternal
they're fraternal so it'll be a totally
different experience because I think you
know having someone with the same DNA it
feels like your whole life is an
experiment like whenever she does
anything amazing I'm like like why am I
not doing that we're like the same
person I should be able to do that too I
think the fraternal it's less pressure I
think less pressure but there's still
something there I have relatives or
fraternal twins there's still there's
still some unusual connection there okay
but I don't want to take us too far off
the reservation here but I am fascinated
by this stuff and you know I was it
partially get us reading the at the
beginning of the book the new book the
SuperBetter book and there were a couple
of things that jumped out of me the
first was in effect let me just find it
here there's a line that reads but even
when I still had the symptoms even while
I was still in pain I stopped suffering
and I think this is a really important
concept because less sure if this from
the military or elsewhere but I've heard
pain pain as mandatory suffering is
optional right or or pain is inevitable
separate optional which is a Buddhist
saying actually oh well there we go
Buddhist special operations for
so I think this is really important
because like you said it's not
necessarily about eradicating all
negative experiences which is not
possible but about increasing if you
have two bank accounts one of negative
experiences and one of positive you just
want to make sure that the balance and
the positive is higher than in the
negative could you talk a little bit
about post-traumatic growth sure yeah so
you know the idea of a gameful mindset
is that it's exactly that that you look
at pain as inevitable but but suffering
is optional because if you think about
when you play games you're always trying
to suffer when you play games like games
are voluntary suffering you think about
golf you know if in real life your goal
were to get a small ball in a small hole
you would just walk up to the hole and
you would put the ball in it and you
would be happy with the outcome but you
volunteer to suffer by standing really
far away from the hole which is a stupid
way to achieve the goal and then you use
like the stick to try to aim the ball
which it's also pretty inconvenient so
every game we play is like Scrabble the
same way you know you don't get
unlimited letters you only get the seven
letters and we're gonna you can't even
pick them yourself so it's like it's
it's a voluntary suffering things are
harder than they should be and that's
what unleashes the creativity and the
curiosity and the optimism and the
recruitment of friends and resources so
the gameful mindset is really about how
do you look for voluntary obstacles in
real life how do you look at things that
you are currently experiencing as
suffering as instead a way to get
stronger or happier and then that's
where the idea of post-traumatic growth
comes in which is not not all that new
field of research now is probably a
decade's worth of research now showing
that many people who undergo a traumatic
experience in addition to suffering and
by the way post-traumatic growth it's
not the opposite of post-traumatic
stress disorder that's a misconception
that many people sort of stumble on to
most people with post-traumatic growth
first experience post-traumatic stress
disorder so just because you have one
doesn't mean you can't ultimately wind
up with growth and it's a process where
by wrestling with these really difficult
things you get to know yourself better
so at the end of post-traumatic growth
you feel like you understand your
strengths better you feel like your
friends and family understand you better
you feel like you you know your
priorities and life better and you have
more courage to make decisions so that
you're putting your time and energy on
the things that matter most to you it's
kind of similar in that way to a
near-death experience a lot of people
have near-death experience suddenly they
relish every day they're not afraid to
speak their minds they really do put
more time on their personal dreams or
spending time with friends and family so
post-traumatic growth is the same way
but you only get it by really wrestling
with this incredible almost existential
crisis in your own life which for me was
the traumatic brain injury and not
knowing whether I would ever work or
really be myself again but it can take
the form of setting a goal like running
marathon or fill in the blank
right Clos yeah this is so this is there
have been now a couple books about
post-traumatic growth but I am happy to
say that I have the first book on post
ecstatic growth which is a concept that
was originally discovered by this
amazing researcher and Marie Ricci at
University of Pennsylvania not a lot of
people are familiar with her research
and I'm hoping this book will shine a
spotlight on it she found that many
people seem to be exhibiting
characteristics of post-traumatic growth
by doing things that they had chosen for
themselves and that were not you know
traumatic experiences per se although
there might be trauma involved so
training for a marathon becoming a
parent for the first time starting your
own business
going on that kind of spiritual journey
like at like a physical Mecca somewhere
things that are really challenging that
you will probably fail at at some times
you know make mistakes
struggle and that really force you to
cultivate that same understanding of
your own strengths
out to friends and family taking stock
of your priorities it turns out you can
have all the benefits of post-traumatic
growth without the trauma which is you
can merit yes and so that's that's why
you know this super better method is
basically a roadmap to post-traumatic
growth if you have an illness or injury
or if your life is pretty good and you
still want to get all these amazing
benefits helping you define for yourself
a challenge that will be meaningful and
and difficult enough but also doable
that you can get to these benefits so
I've to one observation and then a
question the observation when I was
reading this and also just listening to
your description and talking about for
instance the post-traumatic growth
following a near-death experience which
is of course not something that you it's
dangerous to try to engineer near-death
experiences in the literal sense
although a lot of people do right I mean
there's you know people people pursue
extreme sports and things like that
because of that that ability to really
see so clearly what you want out of life
you well I'd magnifies it really
exaggerated a lot of the emotions and
provides clarity in those moments in
some cases and I couldn't help but think
about a the wife of a friend who used to
work in hospice care and she would
palliative care she would sit with
people in them in the weeks and then
moments before they passed on before
they died and she wanted she it turned
out she was basically a Michael Jordan
in that capacity she was really good at
guiding people through that but she
wanted to have the opportunity to help
more people and she ended up then
working with psychedelics to help people
hmm simulate that type of near-death
experience and I don't we don't have to
take we don't have to go far down this
road but I mean I've had conversations
for instance on the podcast with Jim
Fadiman who
talks quite a lot about micro dosing but
also the use of higher doses for these
what some people would call spiritual or
mystical experiences yes well this is
actually very interesting because you
know when I was at Berkeley doing my PhD
I actually wrote a research paper on the
commonality of experience of people who
are playing these certain types of games
these kind of very collaborative
collective intelligence games and these
spiritual drug-taking you know like the
Psychonauts they call themselves right
actually because because so that's
something I've actually been interested
in for you know a very long time because
there is I do think there is a spiritual
element to a lot of gameplay in that
that sense of really wanting to open
yourself up particularly in in games
that require you know to be a part of a
massive community and part of these kind
of epic narratives like you know Joseph
Campbell's hero's journey there there is
definitely a spiritual element to that
and a lot of spiritual benefits that
come out of gameplay which which is you
know maybe that I might for my third
book I keep saying I want to write a
book called Super Mario was a Buddhist
maybe maybe maybe we should come back to
that episode 800 Super Mario was in the
Buddhist special-ops as we've as we
mentioned earlier actually I actually
got to go to a Buddhist conference and
give a keynote with like all the most
important Buddhists in the world were
there and actually gave a keynote called
Super Mario was a Buddhist but I had a
question mark after the title gives you
an out yeah if there's a crowd mutiny I
crowd exactly not some games let me it
doesn't like to ask a personal question
and this is because I I love playing
games
I was I was Dungeons & Dragons
aficionado / obsessive growing up and
that was my refuge I mean I was I was a
real kind of runt dork growing up and
got beat up in elementary school and
whatnot so I
used Games's way to escape but also his
way to to live this sort of virtual life
that enabled me to I think in many ways
develop characteristics I wanted later
in life right and but when people ask me
now like oh are you a gamer I don't know
how to answer that because when I look
at how slick the games are that have
been developed and how much money has
gone into developing games that are as
addictive as possible I choose not to
play those games out of fear and the
fear is the same fear I would have if I
tried heroin people you know if someone
asked me like give you tried heroin I'm
like no I haven't I'm sure I'd love it
and that's the problem like I don't want
to become a heroin addict and I worry
about becoming one of these people who
say sinks 40 to 60 hours a week into
World of Warcraft because I know I have
that capacity right now I know it's
there so how what are ways that people
can reintroduce yeah gameful mindset or
gameplay yeah let's just say it's
somebody who's working 80 hours a week
and they recognize they're like you know
I want the joy and all of the promises
of a gainful mindset and or a gameplay
but I don't want to go off the deep end
and end up becoming completely consumed
yeah yeah you know I can really relate
to this by the way you know I people ask
me about my favorite games of all time
are and I always have World of Warcraft
in the top you know three or four think
of the best games of all time but I only
played it for a very short time because
I saw what my future was going to be
like if I didn't get out quickly and I
always my husband died our plan is you
know when we're retired and old and
maybe unless they've invented life
extension technologies so that like at
150 we're running around like a 20 year
old assuming the old age is similar to
how it is today I'm gonna be totally
addicted to these games when I'm like 90
because it'll have all these cognitive
enhancing benefits and I'll be socially
connected to other people so I'm I'm
waiting to get addicted until it really
is better than you know trying to live
my old life but
there's lots of things you can do and I
should just say also as a sort of public
service announcement benefit one of the
things that I write about in the book
there is a chapter an entire chapter on
what makes a difference between somebody
who benefits from playing games and
brings a gameful mindset to real life
and somebody who develops some kind of
addictive or pathological or compulsive
gaming behavior and there are two things
that predict whether you will benefit
and be gainful in real life or whether
you will kind of get addicted and the
rest of your life starts to suffer so
the two things that are predictive one
is really simple it's 21 hours a week
that is the tipping point I've looked at
all kinds of studies from you know
people in the military to you know young
elementary school students 21 hours a
week when you go over that we start to
see suffering in other aspects of life
such as physical health mood your
ability to do well at school or at work
or other aspects of your life so three
hours a day three hours a day but you
could you could you know pile up on the
weekend I mean doesn't have to be yeah
and so I always say if you if you feel
like you're addicted or you have a
family member who you fear is addicted
do not take the games away because as
you learn about reading the book games
are very powerful they they help treat
or prevent depression and anxiety and if
you take games away from somebody who's
gaming 30 40 50 60 hours a week you're
basically like taking them off in
antidepressant without tapering and
we've seen a lot of people who I mean of
many cases of people committing suicide
young people when their parents have
taken away the games and and it's not
just that they're upset or angry it's
that literally the brain has had this
powerful antidepressant ripped away from
them so so just go down to 20 hours a
week is that is that is one piece of
practical advice for people who are
really dealing with addiction or
compulsion do not give it up just get it
down to 20 hours a week and that's
actually very manageable for most people
even people who are feel like they they
love to play they don't want to give up
games you can get it down to three hours
a day and so that's that is a practical
tip but the other thing that predicts
negative outcomes or you're just not
getting the benefits of games in real
life is looking at games as escapist so
I was really interested to hear you say
that you know you thought about games as
escaping but you also maybe thought
about them as a way to build these kind
of character strings so it turns out the
number one predictor of who will suffer
from gameplay it's people who think that
games are an escape from real life or a
way to avoid thinking about or dealing
with real problems people who manage to
bring the game full mindset and all the
benefits to games to the real lives are
the people who identify benefits to
gameplay and can talk about them and can
it can identify them and can say you
know I'm not I'm not just playing candy
crush or call of duty because I just
can't deal like I just need to just shut
everything off they're the people who
say this is quality time you know for me
and my brother and when we play this
game together this is this is a real
benefit to my life or you know I'm
playing this game because I'm having
really anxious thoughts and I want to
shut them off and I know if I play this
game for 10 minutes I can shut down I'm
not gonna have a panic attack
so if you have a real purpose for how
you play that's when you start to build
up the self-efficacy to use the gameful
strengths in real life now that that is
not so you're asking like a very
practical question like what should i do
or what should i play literally 10 to 20
minutes a day if you do 10 minutes every
day or 20 minutes three times a week
that's what's been tested in clinical
trials and randomized control studies to
have powerful impacts first and foremost
on depression and anxiety improving your
mood for social interactions 10 minutes
a day improves the number of people you
have in your life who will help you with
a real life problem so I think of it as
just it's like you know I make time to
do you know 10 push-ups during every
commercial of all tennis that I watch on
TV so you should think about it that way
like how do you squeeze in a little bit
of game play into your downtime so that
was what I would recommend so what type
what I have to ask now of course since
you mentioned it what what's on your top
5 game list or whatever the just
a handful of your favorite games but
then also for someone like me who
doesn't want to get sucked into the
vortex yeah I it feels like I should
probably stay away from worlds building
games in that case yeah and maybe go
with the cut more transactional kind of
tetris type of game or something that
allows me a closed short session but
what it what are some of your favorite
games what are kind of on your your your
hits list and then what might be games
that I could use for those 10 to 20
minutes a day yeah and what should my
intention be going into them right yeah
yeah okay so I'll just I'll just
I mean I'm well we don't do like an
all-time favorite games we'll just talk
about because otherwise like I'd be like
Dance Dance Revolution totally on my top
10 all-time but you know nobody plays
that anymore okay okay
so Tetris is is definitely I mean
everybody should have that on their
phone because it treats so many
different conditions from anxiety to you
know push my stress order to you know
building up your willpower
so Tetris everybody should have Tetris
games that other people you know are
playing is really really good and so
this changes depending on the time so a
lot of people are playing clash of clans
right now or candy crush saga or worth
with friends you should just check out
what people that you know are playing
because a lot of the benefits that have
been documented for games comes just
from having these sort of micro
conversations with friends and family
about the same game that you're playing
or actually playing in game with them so
any of those three games would be good I
think minecraft is really great even
though it's like the most popular game
of all time for kids now it's actually a
really great resilience building game
for grown-ups
you know because if you're you know if
you if you if you die if you have your
stuff blown up and you have to kind of
start over again it has the qualities of
the kind of game that we know builds
resilience builds determination and
willpower that can benefit you in real
life so yeah if you
by the way if somebody has not played
minecraft they've like missed out on one
of the biggest cultural gifts you know
of our of our generation so haha but
that's me looking down at my feet right
now so I'll get on it okay so definitely
do that so that because the next
generation that's like all that's gonna
be their number one nostalgia point like
all you're gonna hear about 20 years
from now or like people in their 20s and
30s talking about minecraft so it at
least expose yourself and then I think
puzzle games single-player puzzle games
or single-player adventure games are
really good for provoking positive
emotions and so portal is something I
always recommend to people there's their
portal and portal 2 it's incredibly
challenging but hilarious puzzle game
that even though it's the first one
single-player you can play the second
one co-op which is really cool in fact
when I was playing portal 2 with my
husband and we were also training for a
half marathon at that time we actually
use our portal skills to better navigate
like all the people that we were trying
to run around and pass in the race we
would use the same gestural system that
you use in in the video game to
communicate with each other like how we
were going to get around all these
people and still then come back and run
together so I thought poor ttle to that
so yes those are some those are some
good some good games to start with and
but but but really any game that you
love including I mean you could be
playing pandemic the board game you
could be playing poker I mean you could
be playing bridge or golf whatever most
games even if they're not video games
also help you develop that the game flow
mindset and what is your I mean you
clearly have you've got some babies you
got some dogs you got a husband you have
at least one or several jobs what is
your sort of that weekly let's just say
this past week or next week what is the
what does the workout schedule look like
with the gaming
like what it's uh yeah what it's where
do you where do you squeeze it in what
time of day how many times a week yeah
okay well so first of all with two
babies like I literally cannot play
anything on a console now because I only
at best have one hand like one thumb
basically so we're talking strictly
games on my phone and so for me candy
crush saga it's the best one to be
playing now because both my
parents-in-law play and they are helping
us take care of our baby so you know
when they come over I can give my
father-in-law a baby to feed and I can
take his phone and try to get him off a
level that's you know because I'm like
400 levels ahead of him so I can you
know take his bone and help him get off
the level and now he's happy because
he's ahead a level and I'm happy because
he's feeding the baby
so can't for me that's actually really
important like using games as a as a
cultural touchstone or piece of you know
a common experience with other people
and my mom's also playing and so that's
that's really helpful and then I also
you know I play tennis with my husband
once a week which is really good for me
because if I lose 6-0 6-1 that is an
amazing match for me like I I won one
game he's you know he's six foot three
he's a dude he's like it's I get
clobbered so CJ is he just like a
hundred mile and airing and bad I don't
know my numbers that might be slow I
don't know but I mean I mean is he just
going to like being you is he going for
the kill or is I mean I finally just
convinced him like three or four weeks
ago to serve such that I could return
literally he was it was like it was my
only points for like if he
double-faulted but but that's a really
good game from you that I play once a
week because like I I'm kind of killing
it in other areas of my life you know I
feel like very successful in other areas
of my life and I think getting clobbered
once a week in a game that I'm very bad
at and they'll just think this this is
documented to be true if
you can take the clobbering and stay
optimistic and still have positive
emotions throughout that experience it
builds a lot of psychological resources
that you will be able to draw on when
it's on a game but when it's real like
yeah so okay so I'm getting clobbered in
tennis once a weekend which day of the
week what time of day I love the
specifics like so like how many times a
week five days per week you playing
candy crush saga and then yeah what day
of the week on tennis yeah Candace okay
the questions every day and you know
what I would say I probably look at it
you know twice a day maybe in the
morning I make sure to spin the wheel to
get my free powerup I might not play it
but I'm like I don't want to forget to
get because every day in candy crush
you'd get one free powerup otherwise
they charge you like you know 99 cents
for it so I make sure even like when I'm
traveling and giving talks in other
countries and have no time for anything
I always log in once a day and spin to
get so I kind of like the stash of
power-ups or when I'm on a really hard
level so do that in the morning and then
later in the evening I'll I will do it
but I find it's actually good for me
before I go to sleep because I have one
of those minds that will anxiously race
about all the things that I have to do
tomorrow and so we know actually but
there's a there's a set of quests and
power-ups and bad guys for insomnia in
SuperBetter and so I know one of the the
tricks for that one of the ways you
battle the bad guy of a sort of
ruminating on things you have to do
tomorrow is to totally occupy your brain
with something else for ten minutes so I
find that to be a good kind of nightcap
for me that's a great idea maybe that's
how I get my Tetris because I've used
fiction for that but sometimes I just
don't have the concentration exactly for
action and then the tennis is on tennis
is on Sunday afternoons and yeah that's
when we get we get are his parents
babysit for us and we go laughs yeah so
get it on the calendar people listening
he can't just improvise your way through
the entire week it's very helpful to get
on the calendar
yeah let me ask a handful of last
questions I know that I want to be
respectful of your time and make sure
that your kids aren't climbing up the
window cells or something but when you
think of the word successful who's the
first person who comes to mind and why
oh my goodness
I've heard you ask that question to
someone else too and they were totally
stumped too I think okay wait I was
gonna say Bill Gates which first of all
is very boring and also it's a man and I
really want to answer a woman so I'm
gonna because I that's something I spend
a lot of time doing like making sure
that I don't accidentally talk only
about successful men even in my book
like you know a lot of I make sure I'm
citing a lot of women scientists because
it's oftentimes the first person we
think of as a man because they're so
often talked about more so okay I like
to say I think of Elizabeth Warren was
actually the next name that came to mind
senator Elizabeth Warren because I think
she is doing an amazing job of pushing
back against powerful interests in this
country and getting us to talk about
making big changes to to our financial
system and our political system and it's
really hard for anybody to get any
traction in that in this country today
so that was who I thought of and maybe
that's actually it might be wishful
thinking because I would love to see her
run for president so maybe I'm maybe I'm
using my futurist forecasting skills
here to think that you know in 2024 she
has just successfully been elected
president and that's why I thought of
her is the most successful person I
could think of cross your fingers
everybody Nostradamus in fact said
speaking of successful women there are a
number of exercises in the beginning of
SuperBetter and I did actually go
through these exercises including the
the quests I should say yeah so I I
actually did both of these so I was in a
coffee shop and one
you know stand up and take three steps
or make your hands into fists hold them
over your head as high as you can for
five seconds so I did both in this
coffee shop and I pretended to be
stretching because as it turns out five
seconds is pretty long but I love these
these comfort challenges and then there
was the for instance the snapping of the
fingers exactly fifty times and these
very very small things looking out the
window for certain periods of time and
so on then I found really fun to do even
as comfort challenges I just enjoy
anything that that allows you to
practice being uncomfortable but how
it's oh all right
the line that struck me was I've watched
some amazing people complete the same
four quest you're about to undertake
including Oprah Winfrey legendary
skateboarder and entrepreneur Tony Hawk
and then it goes on so how did how did
you get Oprah to do these exercises
right that was sorry I actually I was I
was on tour with with Oprah on her life
class show not actually doing anything
on stage with her but I was we created a
game together called the thank you game
Oprah's Thank You game and it was a game
designed to spread gratitude to as many
people as possible because gratitude is
contagious and has all these amazing
life and health benefits and so so I've
made a game for her and and somewhere
along the way I mean I had gotten a
phone call from people from her people
who had they stumbled across some
scientific research and they saw my name
associated with it and I mean I just got
very lucky that that her and her team
were kind of suddenly interested in in
games and and gameful psychology and it
was the first time I met her I'd had
meetings with her team like a dozen
times and I was like in a conference
room and she comes in and gives me a big
hug and says I love you which was like
having I basically look at her at
something like saved my life as a kid I
watched her every day after school and
like she really I I felt like I was
going to therapy watching her show
she's yeah yeah I was like I cannot like
literally her saying I love you I felt
like I could have died on the spot and
like my life would have had a full
karmic circle like I was totally okay
with that
and but we just started talking about
the power of games and I said you know
let me show you the game that I'm
working on now and uh and had her an
edge and I didn't know she was gonna
actually do it and play along and she
did and it was freakin awesome and and
that that led into making the the
Oprah's Thank You game where we we
spread gratitude I think it was like how
many people did we get to is was like
over a hundred million people which is
pretty amazing read The Oprah effect
yeah million people like oh yeah just
another hundred million people what do
you want here incredible what is the
book that you've given most often as a
gift or any books that you've given a
lot as gifts there are two one is called
finite and infinite games which is by a
professor of Religious Studies at New
York University named James cars' and
it's it's basically a book about games
but then it turns out it's about the
meaning of life you don't know until the
last page it's like this big shock it's
like sixth sense that you thought you're
reading a book about games and then
suddenly it's like the return of the
last line of the book is there is but
one infinite game and then you're like
oh [ __ ] its life life is the infinite
game and so that's it and it's like a
really easy it's a tiny tiny box it's a
practically a pocketbook so anyone is
interested in philosophy and looking at
games as look at the way of life that's
a really good one and then a book
well it's called suffering is optional
actually so inspired my favorite
Buddhist teacher sherry Huber and it's
so that is I'm very inspired by Buddhist
practices I mean I I I practice Zen
Buddhism myself and that's what I think
that gameplay and Buddhist
practice are both a way to arrive at a
similar approach to life and so that's
that's another good book what was her
last name Huber hu b e are awesome she's
an amazing podcast too by the way so if
people who love your podcast they can
listen to her podcast you just
interviewed I'm not sure if you know the
name Tara brach but she's she's an
amazing teacher and focuses on
mindfulness and Buddhist teachings and
some just fantastic and I think that
this has been a really interesting week
for me because it's tying together a
bunch of seemingly disparate activities
so you have the say Buddhist philosophy
and teaching then you have stoic
philosophy of course which I've read a
ton of and just a huge fan of whether
it's Seneca or Marcus Aurelius or others
and then you have the game play and they
seem they serve very similar they can
help you achieve very similar outcomes
it's very fascinating do you have a
favorite documentary any favorite
documentaries well I have to plug
documentary called gamers which was made
in 2003 I think and it was the first
full-length feature documentary about
competitive video game players at the
time it was a cyberathlete professional
league the CPL now of course you've got
like League of Legends finals like more
people attended bought a ticket attended
League of Legends finals and the Stanley
Cup finals this year so but this is from
2003 and it's available in its entirety
on YouTube so you can just like watch it
for free and that was but that was a
fascinating documentary that I think as
a years past and competitive video
gaming becomes even more a part of our
mainstream athletic lives but that early
look at it is a pretty damn cool have
you seen king of Kong king of Kong you
want to talk about like old school
mullet vengeance retro video game
competition so amazing so yeah for
I will definitely check out gamers and
for people who haven't seen king of Kong
it seems like a spinal tap sort of
parody like a mockumentary it is such a
hilarious it's such a well-done
documentary people take games seriously
which is that's one of the great
paradoxes of play right is that it's
it's only play if it's not serious
except then we take it incredibly
seriously which is which is a which is
good because that unlocks all of our
game full-strength
what what just a few more questions what
purchase of less than a hundred dollars
is most positively impacted your life in
the last say six to twelve months oh my
gosh I would say well this is so I mean
this is not gonna be surprising at all
but I would say a bee or carrier for the
babies
so we live on a hill and every day we
take the babies out for an hour-long
walk half an hour you know trudging up
this really steep hill and coming back
down and being able to leave the house
and get some fresh air and also a great
workout because the babies are getting
fatter every day so it's like like just
just when you're getting really fit
walking up the hill the baby weighs
another pound so I would say my Bjorn
carrier and now is that like a strap
that attaches said fat babies to you or
is that yeah it's like a harness that
you it goes around your back and then
the baby like kind of hugs your chest
ah cool B YB j bj bj o RN yeah Bjorn
yeah it's it's you know the babies this
is this is progressive resistance for
moms it's kind of like the story of I
think it's mellow or my love Crotona who
who every day had to pick up a baby bull
calf and and lifted over a fence and
then of course the story goes you know
as became a larger and larger bull he
became the strongest strong man in the
world so yeah and this is such a great
way to tie back to video games because
the one of the reasons why video games
are tend to be even better for your
gameful mindset than other games is that
they always get harder right there's a
right it's
right so you're it's like not like chess
where it's very hard to find somebody
who's just slightly better than you
every single time you play this is video
games are designed to be that kind of
progressive resistance so you're always
playing at the edge of your ability
therefore always getting better
that's such a such an important point
I'm really glad you brought that up
what morning rituals do you are what
morning rituals are important to you I
mean I'm a terrible person so I will
confess I okay so there's a neuroscience
hack in here so when I wake up I
basically like put on tennis like like
today's whatever the latest like last 24
hours matches are on TV like I'm
constantly recording on the tennis
channel or ESPN the live tennis and and
then I do a mail while I'm watching
tennis and I spend an inordinate amount
of time watching things like when I
started my startup company for a super
better I would like disappear for eight
hours to go watch you know the French
Open live like that was just you know
part of my that's that's working with
Jane is she will go disappear and watch
tennis for you know eight hours a day
for for two to three weeks treach's
but but it's a good neuroscience hack
because all this is true for all
professional sports every time you make
a prediction about something your brain
increases the amount of dopamine that it
has access to because it anticipates
either success you've successfully
predicted what would happen so that's
great or you'll learn from your mistakes
so you'll learn information that will
make you have a better prediction next
time and every time you get a little
boost of dopamine it's like it's like
taking amphetamines right so I like to
start my day with watching a tennis
match because I will have a prediction
about who I think will win and then I
will either be right or wrong and I will
either feel super awesome that I was
right or I will learn something about
how somebody is playing right now and
what their game is like right now and
I'll make a better prediction next time
and so it's like it's like basically you
know it's like a really strong cup of
coffee or taking an amphetamine giving
my brain that kind of a boost every
morning but you can any you know any if
you have a sports tea
that you like that's why people who are
really interesting on sports are happier
during the sport season than off season
it's not just that they miss their
favorite game is that their brain is
constantly anticipating success for
their favorite team which is increasing
dopamine so I like tennis because they
only have one month off all year they
play for 11 months the season is
incredibly long you can get your fix
yeah no is there I wasn't expecting to
ask this question but now that you
mentioned watching tennis I love
watching tennis mesmerised by it's true
for a handful of individual sports like
gymnastics also same story is there any
have any studies been conducted looking
at the carryover benefits of observing
game play as opposed to being involved
in it yourself yes oh yes so because but
it only works if you know how to play
the game yourself and if you know how to
play the game you activate mirror
neurons so I have found if I if it's
during Wimbledon or the French Open it's
a US Open I've been watching literally
eight hours a day for two weeks I will
go on the court that Sunday and play
better because because I know how to
play tennis and my brain can physically
embody like if I see somebody going for
a point my body my brain understands
what that feels like and so it creates a
mirror neuron effect so it's practicing
so if you have never played the game or
sport yourself like watching gymnastics
is not going to do a lot for you unless
you have physically been on the mat or
on the rings or the bars and you know
what it feels like but if you know what
it feels like then your brain practices
while you play and it actually is
beneficial and that that has been
documented so if you want to get the
benefits of watching a sport you should
make sure you've played it enough times
that your your body can your brain can
follow along in that year in our own way
so that that brings up all sorts of
interesting ideas such as for instance
if you knew that if I knew I was going
to have a surgery that was going to take
me out of commission from a sports
standpoint for three to six months I'm
just making that up
if I didn't know how to play tennis I
could do like a three-day intensive or
two-day intensive immersion course
tennis and then use watching tennis
there there reputedly when I'm laid out
for the subsequent period of time you
are so good at this I love the way your
brain works like I beg that is such an
awesome and extreme idea
I really think you and I should write a
book together sometime we should take
like all of that would be that would be
something new and interesting you could
take all of this research to that
extreme really life maximizing level in
ways that I would never think about
genius all we need to hang out more we
need I agree
the just I keep on saying a few more
questions Fe thank you
five minutes Turkish like that guy
snatch but anyway see if you had a
billboard you could put anywhere I could
say anything what would it say and where
would you put it oh my god I will I
would get a billboard that says I I mean
I really want to do a public service
announcement about Tetris you know I
would I would about how Tetris can
prevent post-traumatic stress disorder
and I would put it you know I don't know
where I would well you should put it in
games really I should use you know you
can like buy advertising in video games
so I should have I should have a
billboard in in video games so that
people who are open to this idea of
games and playing them and benefiting
from them because they it really makes
me that there's so much good research
that would have such profound I mean the
difference between getting pgc and not
getting PTSD and what that would have on
your life is so freakin profound that I
really feel like I would like to I'd
like to get in people's faces about that
so you know temp 10 minutes of Tetris
after a trauma done right that's my
billboard I love it and I mean I want to
play with Tetris I grew up playing
Tetris on the Gameboy so it doesn't take
a lot to twist my arm
to get back into it but
I heard a phrase recently which was a
take on PTSD but it was related to
worrying about things so having anxiety
about what might happen and they and it
was called pre traumatic stress disorder
and I wonder I'll do some
experimentation and report back to you
but I wonder if Tetris could have an
inoculating effect against experiencing
trauma or even foreseeing trauma because
you would imagine I sense that worrying
is a visual often a visualization it
might have the same type of kind of
decoupling or for coupling effect that
minimizes the the negative I don't know
oh yeah well as you get further in the
book you'll see actually it's Super
Mario that's been tested for basically
exactly that things it sort of prevent
the predictive anxiety now I'm better
than anti-anxiety medications I need to
play more games that that is clear and
it's such a nice day I think I want to
go whack a tennis ball around so if you
could make one ask of the people
listening or a recommendation aside from
of course the book and I'm going to III
will put everything in the show notes
but what what ask a recommendation would
you make of the people listening I would
encourage people to ask one person in
their life what is their favorite game
and it could be any kind of game doesn't
your video game and and what it is that
they think that game makes them good at
because one of the things that I found
in my research is the best way to ensure
that somebody starts to use or gameful
strengths in real life is to talk about
what games they play and what those
games make them good at so if we could
have everybody ask one person that
question not only will you learn
something really interesting about
someone you care about but they will
also benefit from now starting to think
about their gameful strengths and then
maybe how they might apply them in real
life
well Jane dear you and I should get
together and scheme like Pinky and the
brain to come up with some type of
massive experiment that we love it I
love it we should we should definitely
make that happen this is this is really
fun Jane where can people find out
everything about you
and learn more about SuperBetter and
also say hi to you on Twitter Facebook
or wherever you might be active yeah I'm
super active on Twitter I'm a vaunt game
a VA NT game but you just search for my
name my website's Jane McGonigal com
but I have another site that I think
everybody who listens to you maleic
which is show me the science yong-nam
where I collect all of the studies that
back up all of the things that I'm
encouraging people to do with games so
and you can actually get the full
academic article if you're a geek like
me and read it and so you know you don't
to take my word for it everything that
I've said in the book I have I've
literally a thousand studies online that
you can click through to and read
yourself so that you can be the key
click me so it show me the science like
show me the money show me the money you
just brought up all sorts of visuals for
me Nazi Cuba Gooding jr. danced around
with his shirt off play Tetris the block
the imagery well Jane it's always so
much fun to hang out virtually or in
person we need to hang out more
everybody listening check out
SuperBetter a revolutionary approach to
getting stronger happier braver and more
resilient I am stoked to go play some
more games I'm gonna do that today and
make it happen and everybody is
listening show notes links everything
will be at 4:00 hour work week dot-com
forward slash podcast all spelled out so
you'll be able to find links to
everything and Jane thank you so much
for taking the time thank you you're
awesome you're one of my heroes so this
is really amazing to get to do well I
feel the same about you so we will we
will we will go hatch some plans and
everybody thank you so much for
listening and until next time
game on
this episode is brought to you by
99designs or one stop shop for all
things graphic design related I've used
99designs for everything from banner ads
to book covers including sketches and
mock-ups that led to the 4-hour body
which later became number one New York
Times number one Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming a lot of it took place
with designers from around the world and
here's how it works whether you need a
t-shirt a business card a website and
app thumbnail whatever it might be you
submit that project and designers from
around the world will send you sketches
and mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out
it's tasty but more important it will
help you not screw up when you're doing
your nutritional plantings for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind
puts a lot in my body and check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
and until next time thank you for
listening